I love how by the way something uh I
thought of this the other day it all
started with Donald Trump being like an
agent of Russia you know and now
literally the thing that they're getting
him on is that he inflated the price of
his condo like that's how far it's
fallen and by the way who's the victim
of that State Farm Lloyds of London like
an insurance company it's just so funny
like it started with like he was hand
selected by Russia he's been working
with them for years and they elected him
and now he's the president and then
after none of that came true four years
later they're like he said it was worth
38 million it would barely sell for 29
it's like that what that's what you got
after doing all the digging and finding
all of the things after marshalling all
of the resources to pull that guy apart
for years the thing you get him on is
that he inflated the price of real
estate which every developer every owner
everybody has always that's the whole
point of owning real estate is to say
it's worth more than it is and get
someone to buy that and believe that
that's every homeowner in in in in the
BBS going up to the appraiser and going
well I think this is about 600,000 right
and apprais like I don't know we'll see
yeah well I'm just telling you I think
that's what you know up the block that
guy sold for 650 he doesn't even got you
know I got a bar in my back where he
doesn't even have that so this idea that
the only thing we're able to get the guy
onh outside of the January 6 stuff but
like you know which is is formidable I
get it but like this idea that Americans
are going to be enraged that he inflated
the price of his assets that Americans
are going to be like I can't believe it
well that office building he said was
worth 300 million in downtown that was
probably 170 million at best people
can't even comprehend these numbers MH
these are not even comprehensible
numbers to the vast majority of people
that live and draw breath on our planet
they have no idea Manhattan real you
cannot explain Manhattan real estate to
people that don't live here they don't
understand they don't understand why an
office building's worth
$300 million the entire operating budget
of like the county they live in one
building
and the idea that people are going to be
like impassioned by this we are
disgusted we are disgusted that he would
inflate the price yeah it's all it's all
anyone does by the way it's all let's go
open the books on everybody let's go
open the books on all of these
billionaires are you telling me that
billionaires are inflating the price of
their assets to get loans
you can't be serious I am shock I am by
the way Bill Clinton on Epstein Deb 20
times never reported not reported barely
couple articles no one really cares no
one cares multiple times some without a
secret service the biggest human
trafficker that we know of he's on a
plane about no one cares Donald Trump
they're like well you know that that's
not worth what he said it was right he
said it had eight bathrooms in has six
it has a powder room that's a powder
room it's not a full bathroom that's not
a full bathroom it's a powder room it's
psyonic that's not an Eden kitchen what
are you nuts you see he said it was Eden
what about the guy that was on the human
traffickers plate well he's been honest
about his assets that's what I care
about I care about somebody honest about
their assets if you say it's a fifth
bedroom but it's set up as an office and
it doesn't have a window it's not a
bedroom
you go what I don't know it's just very
fun it's such a funny thing only because
it started at the fever pitch of he was
installed by the Russian government you
got to remember that's how it started it
started as he is a now there's reasons
to not like Donald Trump there's reasons
to not want him back as president but
it's very funny to me to start like it's
like if the the the principal of your
school called you in and they were like
uh we think your son is a school shooter
and you go oh my God what happened did
you find a
Manifesto what did you I mean oh my God
you're crying you're on the way there
with your husband our baby's the killer
what did we do wrong I can't believe and
you get there and you find out that like
the reason that they think your kid is a
school shooter is they found him like
you know with his friends like doing
some dumb Tick Tock dance with a gun
thing that there's like there's a gun
like in the Tik Tock dance there's like
a gun like a rap and it's like some rap
song and that's why they're all upset
and you go wait that's why you think
he's GNA murder everybody yeah well we
saw him dancing with a gun like his fake
little gun there and you go what are you
an idiot I mean that's what it that's
what the Trump thing feels like it feels
like you start so
high you can't cash those checks and
then you get down and then now we're at
he's in I mean can you imagine by the
way it started at it is the biggest
Russian intelligence operation in human
history they've got they've installed
the president it was the that's the like
premise of films right that's the
premise of films that Russia has
installed the president of the United
States he's being blackmailed by the
Kremlin because he likes to get peed on
by Russian
and now the movie okay and now so
that's a good movie you pitch that man
I'm all ears I work at a Sony
whatever big movie studio I'm I'm into
that movie I go so wait a minute so
Russia installed this President a
blackmailing them they got a p tape it's
great sit with me for this pitch all
right hey thanks for meeting with us
today okay get this right so the guy's
really rich okay he owns real estate he
inflates the price of it
well here's what I mean by
that market value might be like 200
million he says it's worth like
280 yeah think of that is that not good
is that not a great movie is that not
compelling is that not
compelling to you a rich guy saying he
has more money than he does like every
rich guy is that not a compelling film
but that's how the movie Changed by the
way that's how the movie changed from
this guy was installed by a foreign
government who's been blackmailing him
for years
to um yeah I mean he's that condo is not
worth
that that's literally how it's changed